whatever this thing that's being created
here on Earth it seems to
like to create like to allow its
children to play with certain uh yeah
truths that they hold this subjective
truths that are useful for the
competition or whatever this dance that
we call Life broadly Define not just
humans and and you know I'm glad you
mentioned that because
what I find fascinating is that the
greatest scientists are on record
saying that when they were making their
discoveries they felt like children so
Isaac Newton said to myself I only
appeared as a child playing on the
seashore and every once in a while
finding a prettier Pebble or a prettier
shell whilst I think some he says
something like the infinite ocean of
knowledge
lately was lying before me
Alexander grotonic
who probably it was the greatest
mathematician of the second half of the
20th century the French mathematician
Alexander grotonic
I wrote that Discovery is a privilege of
a child
the child who is not afraid to be wrong
once again to build to look like an
idiot you know to to try this and that
I'm paraphrasing and go through trial
and error that is for them in other
words for them
uh that innocence
of a child who is not afraid
who has not yet been told that it cannot
be done okay
that was essential to Scientific pursuit
to scientific discovery
and now and now also uh compared to
Pablo Picasso a great artist right so
who said every every child is an artist
the question is to how to preserve that
as we grow up
do you struggle with that you're one of
the most respected
mathematicians in the world
uh you're Berkeley you're like this this
is the statue you're supposed to be very
like you know
sometimes I joke I say I I think I take
an elevator to the top of the everything
yeah and you're supposed to speak like
royalty uh do you struggle to like uh
strip all of that away to ReDiscover the
child when you're thinking about
problems when you're teaching when
you're thinking about the world
absolutely I mean that's part of being
human because when we grow up I mean all
of them all of this great scientists I
think they were so great in part because
they were able to maintain that
connection okay in that Fascination that
vulnerability
um that spontaneity you know and uh
um kind of looking at the World Through
The Eyes of a child but it's difficult
because you know you go through
education system and for many of us
uh it's not especially
helpful for maintaining that connection
that we kind of like we are being told
certain things that we accept
take for granted and so on and little by
little and also we get hit every time we
act different okay every time we act
that that's in a way that doesn't fit
sort of the pattern we get punished by
the teachers get punished by
parents and so on and don't get respect
when you act childlike in your thinking
when you are fearless and
looking like an idiot that's right
because there's a hierarchy nobody wants
to look like an idiot you know once you
start growing up or you think you're
growing up yeah at the beginning you
don't even think of you don't um think
in these terms you just play you're just
playing and you are open to
possibilities to this infinite
possibilities that this world presents
to us so how do we I'm not saying that
education system should not be also uh
kind of taming that a little bit
obviously
the goal is balance
that acquiring knowledge
so that we can be more mature and more
discerning more discriminating in terms
of our approach to the world in terms of
our connections to the world and people
and so on
but how do we do that while also
preserving that innocence of a child
and my guess is that there is no formula
for this it is
a life is an answer every life every
human being is one particular answer to
how do we find balance
that's once imperfect approximation
approximate solution
to the problem but we could look we can
look up to the great ones yeah who have
credentials in the sense that they have
shown and they have proved that they
have done something that other humans
appreciate our civilization appreciates
say Isaac Newton or Alexander grotonic
or Pablo Picasso so they have
established their rights
to speak about this matters and we
cannot dismiss them as a mere Madman
they say okay well if the same thing was
said by somebody who never achieved
anything in in that in their in their
field of endeavor you would be it would
be easy for us to dismiss it but when it
comes from someone but like Isaac Newton
we take notice
so I think that's something important
that they teach us and especially today
in this age of AI of course there's a
big elephant in the room always which is
called AI yeah right and so I know that
you are an expert in this subject
and we are going we're living now in
this very interesting times of new uh AI
systems coming online pretty much every
couple of weeks
so
I kind of um to me that whole debate
about
what is it what is artificial
intelligence where is it going what
should we do about it
needs an influx of this type of
considerations that we've just been
talking about
that for instance the idea that
inspiration creativity doesn't come from
accumulation of knowledge because
obviously child a child has not yet
accumulated knowledge and yet the great
ones are on record saying that a child
has a capacity
to to create
and an adult
credits the inner child the inner child
yeah uh for this capacity to create as
an adult you see that's kind of weird if
we take the point of view
that everything is computation
everything is accumulation of knowledge
that just bigger and bigger data sets
finer and finer neural networks and then
we will be able to replicate human
consciousness if we take that point of
view then what I just said kind of
doesn't fit because obviously a child
has not been fed any training data as
far as we know yeah they're perfectly
capable of of you know of distinguishing
between cats and dogs for instance and
stuff like that but much more than that
they're also capable of that
you know wide-eyed in a sort of
perspective
so does can it really be captured that
perspective that sense of or can it
really be captured by competition alone
I actually I don't know the answer so
I'm not sort of trying to
uh to present a particular point of view
I'm just trying to question
um any theory that starts out by saying
life is this or Consciousness is this
because when you look more closely you
recognize that there are some other
things at play
which do not quite fit the narrative